I remind us all because we make fun of
the art of politics that we human beings
were made to live under law and we must
live that way and that is why why it is
right for Calvin Coolidge to ascend that
statesman are the ambassador's of
Providence sent to reveal to us our
unknown cells you'll never get to meet
many nikki Haley is the stage woman
thank you very much
whoo that was scary yeah I didn't know
what he was gonna say it is an absolute
pleasure to be here with you today I
thank you it is an honor I will tell you
I've heard so many things around the
country about hillsdale college but your
biggest cheerleaders and the reason that
I am here is because of Bill and Jen
brodbeck they are tremendous friends
they are great supporters of hillsdale
and I thank you for your support
so I know dr. Aaron told you a little
bit about my story I'm going to tell you
a little bit more because it tells one
why we're here it tells where we're
going and it tells what we can do from
there yes I will always say I am the
proud daughter of Indian parents that
reminded us every day how blessed we
were to live in this country they loved
the fact that you could come to this
country make anything you want it be as
successful as you wanted to be and
nothing was going to get in your way I
did start doing the books for them when
I was 13 it wasn't until I got to
Clemson that I realized that wasn't
normal but what they were teaching me
then was they didn't want me to know
differences they didn't want me to know
difference in gender they didn't want me
to know differences in race they didn't
want me to know the differences in
challenges that hold you back and so as
I moved forward and went on to Clemson
and graduated in accounting and worked
for a corporation I came back home to
the family business and the one thing we
consistently saw in our family business
was how hard it was to make a dollar and
how easy it was for government to take
it I got incredibly frustrated my mom
always said don't complain about it do
something about it and so I decided to
run for the state house I had never been
politically active and did not know you
weren't supposed to run against an
incumbent in a primary i ended up
defeating a the longest-serving
legislature in a Republican primary and
moved on to the State House and quickly
realized that I had defeated the
Legislature's friend it was a Republican
House in a Republican Senate and I met
another person Nathan Valentine who had
defeated the majority leader that year
they were both considered coincidences
couldn't have possibly been true they
were just kind of acts that weren't
supposed to happen but what we did know
was real was the fact that no one wanted
to share a desk with us no one wanted to
share an office with us so we became
desk mates and suitemates and quickly
realized that we were part of a new
group we were the conservatives we were
the reformers and what we were trying to
do was change the way that government
worked and so as we moved forward we
started what we found out was a movement
in South Carolina because the year it
was just the two of
but every year after that we started to
add more to the mix it was starting to
not be about being a Republican it was
about being conservative and so every
term mattered and more and more cane and
so as we grew this movement something
else came to mind you started to notice
other problems within the state in the
state of South Carolina legislators were
not required to show their votes on the
record and it seemed like normal habit
because it was what they had always done
but it came to light one day when they
voted themselves an increase in their
pensions and they passed it on a voice
vote yet to this day you cannot find one
legislator that said they voted
themselves a pay raise I got very upset
I went to my Republican leadership and I
said we are Republicans this is
embarrassing why did we do this and the
next day I filed a bill that said
anything important enough to be debated
on the floor of the house or the Senate
it's important enough for you to know
how your legislature voted our
Republican leadership told me put the
bill away we don't need to have it we
will decide what the public needs to see
and what they don't I knew that I had a
mission I knew that I needed to fight
the fight and so I went around the state
and I said did you know of all the votes
taken in the South Carolina House only
eight percent were on the record did you
know of all the votes taken in the South
Carolina Senate only one percent was on
the record and if you didn't know how
your house member voted ninety-two
percent of the time you didn't know how
your senator voted ninety-nine percent
of the time how'd you know how to vote
when you went to the polls the people
were shocked to put all of this into
perspective my first year in office I
was chairman of the freshman class my
second year I was Majority Whip my third
year I was put on a powerful business
committee and my fourth year I was
subcommittee chair of banking the year
that I wouldn't put the bill away the
year that I wouldn't stop talking around
my state about the lack of
accountability my leadership basically
pulled all of my ranks away I lost
everything was no longer Majority Whip
no longer chairman no longer on the
Banking Committee they pulled everything
I realized at that point I had no pull I
had no clout I had no ability to move
anything in the state legislature
anymore so I ran for governor
I ran for governor with no name ID I ran
for governor with absolutely no money
but what I did have was I had grassroots
I had a conservative message and I had
passion and we went around the state and
we talked about the things we cared
about and in the first year it all paid
off because now in the state of South
Carolina every single legislature has to
show their vote on the record not only
do they have to show their vote on the
record they have to show their vote on
every section of the budget so we
actually get to see the spending habits
of our legislators we also pass the
legal immigration reform we also pass
Medicaid reform and we said that if you
have to show a picture ID to buy sudafed
if you have to show picture ID to get on
a plane you should have to show a
picture ID to vote to protect the one
integrity we have a mistake
and just to make sure that everything
continued to go our way i did a Haley
report card on all the legislators so
every issue that I cared about we told
them what the issue was we told them how
we wanted them to vote and we just went
around and did a series of town halls
and gave them all grades and if they
were good to us and they did the right
things these were not partisan this was
pro-business this was good government
this was tort reform this was illegal
this was restructuring this was making
sure legislators voted on the record we
went and showed their votes to all of
their constituents and we said if they
did the right thing praise them for it
because it's not easy they go up against
a lot of pressure they go up against
leadership but praise them they did the
wrong thing use this as a conversation
piece use it at the ballot box and ask
them why they weren't for it so now our
focus in South Carolina has jobs jobs in
the economy it's the number one focus
that most states have and so when we
look in South Carolina and as we look
across the country what is it that we're
looking for when we're trying to bring
jobs into our state South Carolina is
doing great when it comes to bringing
jobs but the reason we're doing great is
because we're keeping the cost of
business low we just passed tort reform
this year we were the only state in the
southeast that didn't have caps we now
have caps on frivolous lawsuits and have
completely made us competitive on that
front
we knew that permits mattered and so
when it came to our health and
environmental control board I wiped the
entire board clean and now the chairman
of my DHEC board is the president of a
construction company they understand in
state government that time is money and
if an agency is costing a company time
they are costing them money and so we no
longer allow that the second thing is we
have a great trained workforce in South
Carolina because people are your assets
and you've got to make sure that that
happens and then the one that I continue
to be the most proud of we have one of
the lowest union participation rates in
the country and it's paying off because
just in the past six weeks bridgestone
announced their largest investment north
america in a small town in South
Carolina 1.2 billion dollars 850 jobs
two weeks later Continental Tire came in
and announced another 500 million dollar
investment 1,700 jobs in the small town
of Sumter South Carolina today we
announced nephron pharmaceuticals they
announced that they were investing 313
million seven hundred jobs we have gone
in just since January since I've taken
office almost announced 16,000 jobs in
the state of South Carolina since
January
we build planes we build cars we build
tires and now today I've been saying we
make drugs but i have to say we make
medicine in the state of South Carolina
and we're proud to say that we do that
so everything is continuing to go well
but one I am trying to continue to
change what I think is very important
it's not about having a Republican House
in a Republican Senate it's about having
a conservative house in a conservative
Senate that's when we start to move
things and what we did last year was the
unthinkable and I want you to think
about this the state of South Carolina
elected a 38 year old female Indian to
be governor how far have we come
so we're doing great in South Carolina
but I'm going to be honest with you I'm
worried for our country we're seeing
debt and deficits that we never thought
we would see we're seeing mandated
health care that will bankrupt our
state's we're seeing enormous stimulus
spending that has not done anything but
raised unemployment and continued to
give us a loss of a credit rating and
we've seen things that we never thought
would happen in in our country and I'll
give you one example because it's an
example in South Carolina the president
said not too long ago that he wanted to
see things made in America and my answer
to him was I've got some great American
planes in Charleston South Carolina that
we're trying to make and you're holding
us back from doing that we have a great
American company called Boeing and I
know absolutely applauded for them
because they're a great company thank
you I know many of you have heard the
story but I'm going to repeat it over
and over again and I'm going to ask you
to repeat it until every household in
America talks about it Boeing came to
Charleston South Carolina and created a
thousand jobs at a time that our state
needed it at the same time they expanded
2,000 jobs in Washington State not one
person was hurt not one yet the NLRB
comes in and Sue's them it's the most
unamerican thing I've ever seen and it
has to stop now the the good thing I
will tell you is that Boeing and I have
a pact we know that they can't settle
because they understand their fighting
on behalf of every company in this
country I'm fighting on behalf of every
governor in this country and what I will
tell you tonight is between me and
Boeing we will win we will beat the NLRB
but let's think back a little bit think
back to the 1930s we had an economic
crisis that was much worse than this it
was worldwide we had twenty-five percent
unemployment in our response not as
extreme as other countries but it was a
massive government intervention
President Roosevelt's New Deal changed
the way people saw our government
they've changed the way they thought
about it people were suffering and the
private sector was viewed to have failed
so the American people went to their
government for help these government
interventions that we now know is Social
Security child labor laws minimum wage
laws have now become part of the fabric
of America but 75 years later there's a
problem the growth never stopped we
never stopped growing the modern welfare
state is bread debt dependency and
economic stagnation in exchange for
promises of comfort and security we've
surrendered our freedom to government
but the one thing that concerns me is
we've lost the don't complain about it
do something about it that my parents
taught me as I was growing up you always
had a solution you always did something
about it and now we have a president
whose response is to do the exact same
thing a massive government intervention
but the difference is we already have
that we've already done that it didn't
work so as we go forward the great part
I can tell you is that there is hope
because the people don't want it anymore
they now realize that government is not
the answer it's the problem and the hope
that I have is that I have faith in the
American people I know that they
understand that governments time is gone
the private sectors time has begun and
that the best lessons are when we go
through the burn and when we go through
this burn our number one goal is to make
sure we never get back to the situation
again we need people to know the power
of their voice we need them to be loud
about it it is no longer about elected
officials telling us what to do we now
need to tell a lie
did officials what we expect them to do
we can turn things around I know that we
can I know that my parents had faith in
this country I know that I will always
have faith in this country but I will
tell you the movement has begun so our
little movement in the south carolina
statehouse that started with me in a
representative named Nathan Valentine
may have started in South Carolina but
it's now going across the country we
have to support it we have to strengthen
it we have to have faith and know that
this country was meant for great things
thank you very very much god bless you
god bless america
thank you
thank you very much and so now the real
fun begins because I hear we get to do
some Q&A which I love so it's all about
what you want to talk about I think
we've got a couple people in the room
that have microphones am I right about
that and so who wants to ask the first
question oh there we go the leadership
that you've exhibited for the state of
South Carolina in this nation and may
God continue to bless you my question is
twofold first the situation with Boeing
and the National Labor Relations Board
what type of an economic impact has this
had so far in South Carolina and what do
you foresee in the future for other
right-to-work states thank you thank you
you know the interesting thing is this
is not just affecting right-to-work
states this is actually more harmful for
non right-to-work states because what
companies ever going to want to go to a
state is that's not right to work we are
not seeing any economic impact we are
pushing forward we have planes in
production it is a beautiful plant and
I'm ready for those macdaddy planes to
come out of there and they will what I
will tell you has been a little bit
interesting is the unions have gotten a
little bit upset with me and sued me and
told me to quit talking negatively about
them and I said well when you quit
giving me reasons to talk negatively
about you all quit talking smack I will
tell you that the conservative judges
god bless them it's the reason we need
them turned around and ruled the case
down and said it was freedom of speech
and I had the right to say whatever I
wanted
next question
and I said I would like you to tell me
what we can do for our great governor of
the state of Georgia governor deal whom
I love and I work to elect as I did you
but you stand against federal
intervention you stand against them
handing you dollars so you can match
their dollars so you they can leave
South Carolina and you holding the bag
so I want to know what we can do in
Georgia to nudge our wonderful governor
to stand in the right way for this tea
splice for this arc for this rapid rail
that we're doing here in the state of
Georgia because it's going to leave us
holding the debt you know the
interesting thing that we want to remind
every governor in the country and we
need to remind ourselves is government
was intended to secure the rights and
freedoms of the people it was never
intended to be all things to all people
when you think of it that way what we
have done with our agencies is we've
gone through and I've asked every one of
my cabinet agencies to define their core
mission of government and let me know
how many federal dollars they're taking
if those federal dollars don't line up
with that core mission we don't want it
anymore and in most cases you will see
and we just turned down some stimulus
money for education in South Carolina
you can't use one-time money for
reoccurring expenses every business can
tell you that it's the standard rule
when you're running a business the
second thing is there is not a federal
dollar you can take where they don't
have a requirement attached to it it
forces you to do things you wouldn't
normally do states will learn that when
they realize that our budgets are
getting tougher we do have to balance
our budgets thank god i can't wait till
washington has to do that and we have to
make them do that but we have to balance
our budgets and we have to prioritize
and what i told the people in South
Carolina during the State of the State
was I said this year is going to hurt
but if you stay with me I will make sure
we never have to go through this again
that's the decisions governors have to
make it's not fun in South Carolina i
vetoed the Arts Commission got everybody
upset but arts is not what government
was intended to pay for not when
seventy percent of the Arts Commission
was salaries I said we wouldn't give a
charity that money you know why the
world would you give it in government i
vetoed education television in a time of
internet and everything else why are we
funding etv instead of me giving them
ten plus million dollars just because I
said we're going to do a bill for
service if you do a bill for my agency
they will pay you but the private sector
gets to play a role in this too and if
we decide to go with someone else will
pay them that's how we have to think
about government we do it in our
businesses every day government should
not be exempt so what I will tell you is
encouraged governor deal when he does
the right thing and encourage him to
also realize federal dollars continue to
be just a pull on us they really are and
with Washington being in chaos I can't
get us independent enough from them
because I don't want that to be what
leads our state I want us to be
independent and healthy and happy and
you're seeing that with the businesses
were bringing and you're seeing that
with our budgets we started with an 800
million dollar shortfall we ended up
with a surplus it's because we made good
decisions every governor will see that
over time we're going to be forced to
my question is how do you win the next
generation with conservative ideals the
left has always had sort of a machine
should they always had a machine and
academia but how does the right respond
I mean it's really interesting i'm a
young guy and we took note of the fact
that student loan debt cleared credit
card debt both the kinds of debt that my
generation struggles with how do you
convince a generation that didn't go
through a depression that didn't go
through a world war that didn't even
really go through the Cold War that
these realities that lessons from
history of shown us matter now and that
conservatism is really the way to go and
the thing is I think that we have talked
at people but we haven't talked to them
and the one thing that will move people
every day is when you talk about their
wallet and you talk about their homes
and you talk about their liberties and
you talk about their freedoms and just
talk to them I've always told and I tell
my staff we always speak on an 8th grade
level people shouldn't have to struggle
to understand you they should get it I
just spoke to a big group of business
students at the college of charleston
and we had some Occupy Wall Street
people there and we had everybody else
but there wasn't a person in that room
that didn't understand where I was
coming from and it's because I told them
when they left college I wanted them to
get a job and when they got that job I
wanted them to keep more money in their
pocket than I did have them give it to
government and I told him I wanted them
to have more freedom and liberties than
before so that they could make the
decisions for their families and I told
him that I wanted them to understand
that when they were successful we were
going to reward them for being
successful we weren't going to take it
from them and give it to someone else
they get that they get that
and for anybody that thinks that college
students are too young to understand my
13 year old daughter got it because she
heard on the news she heard them talking
about class warfare and she said what is
that are they fighting in class and i
said no i said this is what it's about
just imagine if you studied for a test
and you studied really hard and you made
an a and the person next to you may
daddy and because they thought that you
made me and they may daddy they just
didn't think it was fair so they gave
you a see her first comment was that's
not fair I earned that and I said that's
class warfare so if a thirteen-year-old
can understand it anybody can understand
it any other questions hello thank you
for being here tonight I'm very
inspirational thank you um I was just
curious have you named or a back to
candidate any of the Republican
candidates for president Singh I knew
that was going to come up this is what i
will tell you will i endorse yes i will
endorse and but i will endorse and i
will ask you not to norse we no longer
should elect someone because they look
good in a picture or hold a baby well
if they're not going to fight for us if
they're not going to give us the details
and show results and really tell what
they're about that's not who we want we
need a courageous leader when you see me
endorse it will be me endorsing as a
governor what does the governor am I
looking for in a president because I can
tell you right now we need a president
that understands that our Medicaid costs
are going up and we need block grants we
need as much flexibility as we can as
the governor need to know that a
president when they see that I've got an
issue they understand they've got to
call me back we had an illegal
immigration issue and I called the
Homeland Security office and my director
did too they wouldn't call us back for
three months I had two dozen illegal and
immigration inspectors sitting at their
desk unable to do their work the way i
got president obama's administration to
call me back was i had a press
conference within a week i solved it and
it was done I shouldn't have to have
that happen to do that but we need to
ask the hard decisions I have not
decided I can tell you in South Carolina
it's anyone's game anyone that says that
there's a number one person there it's
just not true the best thing that
happened was we closed the field you
know everybody was waiting for that new
person that new person you know the
field is closed it is what it is what I
will tell you is shame on us if this is
not a one-term president because with
the high unemployment with the credit
rating dropped with the economy the way
it is the ammunition is there it's
whether we're smart enough to be as
strong enough have the grassroots the
conservative mention message and the
passion to make it happen
South Carolina like my home state of New
Mexico is historically struggled in K
through 12 education what are you doing
to reform that particular area of the
state you know education is an
interesting thing in every state and
what we always have to remember is
that's our future workforce that at the
end of the day is what we have to focus
on what we're going to focus on in South
Carolina is reforming our funding
formula right now in our statement in a
lot of states we fund children based on
property tax base it's wrong we have to
fund them on the fact that that is our
future workforce and they deserve a good
education so we are going to start
putting dollars on the child but we're
going to hold our school districts
accountable they now have to show
measurables graduation rates dollars in
the classroom what are they doing to
help and challenged areas there's going
to be several measurables that they've
got to do to show what they're doing to
live up to that in turn we will give
them the funding but we'll give it
flexibility because every county is not
the same some go through different
challenges some may need technology some
may need smaller classrooms but whatever
it is we need to give them the
flexibility to do that when you do that
what you do is the school districts that
do well they get more money the school
districts that are challenged not living
up to those measurables or incentivize
to want to do better and you have to go
to merit-based paid for teachers but
understand absolutely understand that
merit-based paid for teachers doesn't
come from the state level it comes from
the principal and the school that sees
that teacher every day and watches what
that teacher does
the problem we have with education is
we've got great teachers but but our
teachers now have to be the parent and
the pastor and the guidance counselor
and everything else oh and by the way
they have to teach to a test it's wrong
we need to untie their hands and let
teachers do what they do best which is
just teach our kids Governor Haley yes I
Matty part here in South Carolina god
bless you and I love you for that thank
you early on we tea partiers learned two
things rallies wouldn't do it we found
out that we needed power the other thing
we found out was we didn't have any
politics is about power that's the
purpose of it you gave us a great gift
whenever you gave us the requirement
that votes be recorded recorded votes
are the foundational gateway to the
Republic and you gave us that and you
gave us our power want to thank you for
that thank you very much
governor Haley I've been hearing on the
news about a possibility of a third
party candidate what can we do about
that I mean that voice making anything
right now you know I know that
everyone's talking about third-party
candidate and I think that we need to
remember to stay focused and stay on
message primaries are great for a reason
because we debate and we try and find
out who is the best to represent our
party and so initially you have some
that say I could never vote for that
person I could never vote for that
person it's going to happen it happened
with my race that happens in every race
the goal is that we have to understand
that we have to have a one-term
president don't worry about the third
party candidate it's not going to happen
because all of our independence all of
our tea parties all of our gops
understand that anything right now is
better than what we've got
I think how do you deal with public
employee unions well let's first start
with how I deal with unions in general I
think they are so desperately trying to
be relevant god bless them and they're
just not
there was a time in place where I think
they mattered and there is this is not
that time what I can tell you that I am
so proud of in South Carolina is if you
took a union and you put them in Boeing
or you put them in BMW you put them in
Michelin the employees would tell them
to walk out and the reason is our
employers in South Carolina understand
they are not anything without the people
that take care of them and so they have
a direct relationship with their
employees and the employees love that in
terms with the public unions I mean I
think in general even in South Carolina
we're starting to see a little bit of a
distaste because they want to have this
is all about communication that's what
unions are unions are all about trying
to take away that communication trying
to be that voice that talks for
everybody but that's the opposite of
what people want today people want to be
able to speak for themselves they don't
want a middleman in there talking for
them and in South Carolina what we do is
if there's a company that has a threat
of a union we walk in there and we say
I'm just here to let you know how much
your employer appreciates you all they
do is talk about how they wouldn't be
able to do this without you and we go
and we talked about that two companies
all over our state we need to talk about
that across our country you don't have a
union problem unless you have conflict
the unions are trying to create conflict
when you look at Occupy Wall Street look
at who's funding it those are your
unions your unions are trying to create
a distraction them you've got people in
Occupy Wall Street and they're holding
up signs saying I'm mad too you know
honk if you're for liberty there's no
rhyme or reason to what they're trying
to do but the only rhyme and reason that
we do have is that the unions are
funding their offices the unions are
funding their lodging the unions are
feeding them and they're sending them to
different states to do that we have to
continue to spread the word in terms of
the public unions it's about
communication it will continue to be
about communication we are dealing with
the pension issue in South Carolina and
we're going to continue to talk to our
state employees and let them know what
the situation is and let them be at the
table and we think that we'll be able to
handle that any other questions
a two questions here number one when you
are faced with a revenue shortfall how
do you decide which programs to cut and
secondly do you think we face a crisis
in the definition of personal
responsibility I know you do and how do
we deal properly with it I think the
first thing that every governor needs to
do I think it's the one thing that I
pray every day that Washington will do
is go back to that understanding of you
can't be all things to all people you
know I did not make people happy when we
went against the Arts Commission I
didn't make people happy when we went
against education television what I did
say was this is about making the hard
decisions and this is about looking at
what really do we want to be paying for
and what do we want to send to the
private sector for me it's things like
we have a thousand people working in the
department of education right now half
of them work in school bus maintenance
that's not where we need to be putting
money when it comes to education so
we're pushing to privatize our school
buses so that's not an issue you look
for the faults in the system and then
you go to your agencies and you reward
and incentivize them for actually doing
better for saving money for becoming
more efficient and remember what those
core functions of government were its
health care its education its safety
it's not anything more than that what
you find is special interest groups want
to be a part of that core mission our
goal as governor's is to be loud and say
but that's not a that's not the role of
government that's not the core mission
so it takes a lot of courage to do it
and then it takes a lot of Education to
let people know why you did it and then
if you do that you will see a difference
what I will also tell you that every
state is going to start to see so we're
going to start to see our revenues pop
back up we were kind of starting to
breathe we're starting to see things get
a little bit better the number one goal
in every state and should eventually be
in Washington or spending caps we've got
to live by spending caps we do it at
home we do it in our businesses
government can't be exempt from that
when you look at those spending
apps and additional money falls the only
uses for that additional money is a year
to pay down debt or give it back to the
people that paid it in that's the
conversation we're having in South
Carolina
the personal responsibility side goes
back to you know hand up are a handout
and this is creating the conversation
that you know our unemployment situation
the way we're moving it in South
Carolina I'm going to make it so
uncomfortable for somebody to sit on the
couch it's just not the way we're going
to have it in South Korea but i'm going
to incentivize them to want to get
trained i'm going to incentivize them to
want to have training so that they get a
better job that's the way we do it is we
let them know that actually personal
responsibility of doing for yourself and
taking care of yourself is so much more
rewarding than sitting on a couch and
allowing someone else to take care of
you takes a little bit more muscle but
we can do it and it takes a lot of
creativity and you have to let everybody
else think it was their idea but when
you do that great things can happen
said everybody there's 23 more but
they're in the back there's a consensus
that the education system in the country
needs to get fixed and most people well
pretty much everybody hopes that that
happens but what do you think the
consequences will be if our education
system doesn't get fixed and and the
country gets more serious about
education in the near future the best
thing that could happen for education in
our country is for every state to be
able to take care of it themselves I
mean that's the number one thing is
South Carolina is not like Georgia
Georgia is not like Texas Texas isn't
like California we all have different
educational needs and the federal
government has to understand that them
dictating from Washington is just like
health care you can't go and say what
kind of health care we need for our
state and tell us how we need to educate
our children you got to release those
strings and that's a lot of what needs
to happen the solutions that we need to
federal mandates is going to fall on our
governors our governors have to step up
we have to show how it's hurting our
states we have to show how it's hurting
our budgets you're going to see me get
very involved in pulling governor's
together because you put four or five
governors at a podium and the world
watches because governors have nothing
to gain but just helping their state and
so that's what I'm hoping we can have
have happen is I did that with the NLRB
we got all governors all Republican
governors together to say this was wrong
and then we also asked all presidential
candidates to speak on it and it
happened we're going to try and do the
same thing when it comes to Medicaid and
block granting we're going to try and do
the same thing with education if we can
create the conversation for the federal
government to understand that their
constituents need flexibility their
constituents need to have their hands
untied from the federal government
that's going to be the answer education
will be an issue because we've got
training issues we've got international
companies that for the first time in a
long time are looking to invest in the
United States because the dollar is weak
we need to seize that we need to make
sure that we take hold of that
opportunity and take those investment
allow those companies to come but if we
don't have the workforce none of that's
going to matter so we've got to look at
education I think we'll be forced to do
that for some chance that our current
president wins the second term will you
consider running in 2016 he's not going
to win
that's all I have to say about that I
think that was it will listen you have
honored me thank you so very much it's
been a true flavor god bless you
you